un message d'amitié un message
d'admiration aussi pour l'accueil aux
exilés et aux réfugiés ukrainien un
message de soutien à l'intégrité
territoriale un message de solidarité
vous n'êtes pas seuls a martelé emmanuel
macron aux côtés donc de maya sens d'où
la présidente moldave point central de
cette conférence de presse bien sûr la
guerre en ukraine mais aussi la
candidature de la moldavie à l'union
européenne vous est d'ores et déjà
rentré dans l'union européenne a dit
emmanuel macron gauthier rybinski ce
sont des mots ça ne
se limite à ça pour l'instant il y aura
un conseil européen le 23 et le 24 juin
prochain rappelons qu emmanuel macron
est toujours le président
de l'union européenne en tout cas on a
senti qu'il soutenait cette candidature
de la moldavie elle est légitime dit-il
oui parce que jusqu'à présent pour la
france cette région donc autour d'une y
être que ça soit l'ukraine qui est un
très grand pays où la moldavie beaucoup
plus petit ou encore la géorgie tout ça
dans l'esprit des des observateurs et
des experts français des experts proches
du pouvoir politique en général c'était
un peu un terrain à nîmes hans landa
no-man's-land on ne réfléchissait pas
trop à ce à quoi ça pouvait servir on
avait dans la tête que c'était plus ou
moins satellitaire de moscou de fait la
moldavie est une ancienne république
soviétique et donc on avait cette espèce
de de huy de réticences à se mêler des
affaires de ces des endroits de ces
contrées au motif qu' elle serait sous
la dépendance si ce n'est de facto du
moins d' influence russe et donc il
fallait pas s'en préoccuper or là de
fait la présence de moscou et
l'agression de l'armée de poutine en
ukraine force l'occident à réfléchir à
ces endroits ces contrées et la roumanie
certes et déjà depuis longtemps membre
de l'union européenne mais la moldavie
qui est donc très proche culturel
culturellement et également sur le plan
linguistique de la roumanie est elle en
quelque sorte une ré dire un
le mot n'est pas méchant mais un
concentré de ce que peut être la
problématique avec la russie dans la
région la transnistrie elle a été de la
question a été abordée évidemment cela
fait presque un peu plus de 30 ans 92 92
c'est ça un peu plus de 30 ans que des
séparatistes pro-russes donc qui se
trouvent dans cette région réclament le
rattachement à la russie ce pourquoi
d'ailleurs la russie a pris prétexte
pour s'installer dans ce territoire qui
en droit international est un territoire
moldave donc où l'armée russe n'a rien à
faire et de ce fait là ça déstabilise
complètement ce pays qui est en plus
très liée sur le plan économique est
dépendant économiquement de la russie
qui qui plus est à une autre tendance
séparatiste en son sein qui est une
tendance
d'origine turcophones et qu'on appelle
la gagaouzie ce sont les gagaouzes
qu'ils ont
manifesté des velléités d'indépendance
oui que pour un petit pays de deux
millions six cent mille habitants c'est
beaucoup si en plus on ajoute le fait
que cette guerre en ukraine a amené déjà
468 ukrainien à passer par la moldavie
il reste 80 voilà 80 mais certains sont
rentrés mais en tout depuis le février
ses 460 mille personnes qui ont transité
par apple sur un pays de 2 millions 600
mille à vienne le temps et donc qui a
fait cet effort alors bien sûr pour
faire cet effort c'est parce que il ya
cet objectif cette perspective de
l'adhésion européenne et qui dans un
premier temps a surpris les européens
parce que avant la sphère de la géorgie
on ne croyait pas que des contrées aussi
soit orientale puisse être intéressé et
candidater pour une intégration
européenne or là il y a finalement
nécessité nécessité fait loi en même
temps avec des devoirs très grand c'est
que quand vous avez un pays dominé la si
vous le souhaitez quand vous avez un
pays qui jouxte la russie et bien vous
vous engagez que vous l'accueillez dans
un
une instance européenne vous engagé
aussi à ce que ce pays ne soit pas le
premier marche pied ou le premier
piétiner en cas de débordement
fascisto fantasmagorique voyait qui je
pense donc dans ce cas là ça crée des
devoirs et la question qui a été posée à
emmanuel macron à savoir sur la
pertinence de l'article 5 de l'otan
comme modèle pouvant président et à
l'intégration de ces nouveaux pays
évidemment ça ne peut pas être l'article
5 de l'otan parce que ça voudrait dire
que l'europe devrait être une puissance
militaire ce qu'elle nie mais malien à
intervenir en cas d'agression et
intervenir en cas d'agression mais ça ne
veut pas dire pour autant que l'europe
devant ses propres lacunes doivent
baisser les bras et écarté des citoyens
des personnes des peuples qui ont envie
et qui en plus font ce qu'il faut pour
mercy gauthier pour ce débrief après
cette conférence de presse en moldavie
merci d'avoir suivi cette